hey X me PewDiePie and welcome to
Friday's with
Suika ask you bros to submit your best
pewdiepie memes if I know you bros
correct this is probably going to be
pretty [ __ ] to cringey and unfunny just
like me let's watch also new competition
down in the description check it out
it's basically photoshop time boys the
floor is the quality [ __ ] shut up my
success the floor is making video below
expense how to recognize early signs of
autism seems like a very informative and
great video that I would love to watch
also buy a fidget spinner as well to
test yourself today how to respect women
today I'm here with a lovely beautiful
me yeah exactly
this is not true I respect women I want
someone to look at me like PewDiePie
looks at comes he is a beautiful man
he's very tall extremely tall actually
this one is [ __ ] amazing yeah where's
the yeah yeah come on
[Music]
if everyday bro with the busy
Donald ah I've million McMunn it's been
there's been done before you don't
believe me let's have a look hi arch
more means please ah ah look cute
England is my city Oh No
England is my city such a dead meme now
but it will it will stay in my heart in
a very special place forever
also Nick if you want to call me anytime
at night for a little bit of swiggity
swooty booty pop booty you know where to
find me
I'm gonna have to go with me I remember
tweeting this to Miley Cyrus like hey
Miley you stole my outfit it got like
thirty thousand retweets or some [ __ ]
but she never responded nice oh let old
meme but I appreciate it just because PJ
is a whamon it's okay it's just a
handshake yes god damn it god [ __ ]
damn it I love how I looked at my hand
afterwards as well like God stupid had
you you really messed that one up didn't
ya haha
I'll never forget that moment it's
ingrained cemented into my mind anytime
I try to do a handshake I just get PTSD
in I start shaking I just want to play
games smoke cigars drink whiskey and
suck dick
marzia oh that's good to know
the [ __ ] do you find these reaction baby
cry manemma Jeff the floor is try not
yeah get it
the floor is outdated me Kathu kid
upgrade okey ah want some bread yes
that's my favorite one so far hell yeah
everyone scarce here what kind of God do
you take yeah excellent excellent blend
of the green screen I want to give a
second chance after all she's my future
wife you know what they say love is
blind I bet you wish you were this good
at juggling [ __ ] ha ha ha ha that
hurt ow caught it with my ass ha ha ha
hell yeah why did you do it I loved you
why are you so hysterical my idol is a
liar there is one thing that will never
change the brofist I'm sorry you don't
appreciate the fact how progressive my
mind is for thinking about minorities
such as women sorry for respecting
whamming I'm so sorry top 10 legendary I
need to get that car to work again the
battery's all [ __ ] I need a new
battery for it started from the [ __ ]
started from the bottom still at the
bottom how about that
[Music]
that's right
I would never never disrespect the web
if my life depended on it if my if I was
hanging up a click
prepared to die I will what the [ __ ] my
thing making you original content
getting your sentence you don't know
that you don't know that that is not
true
I could I could ease the earth make
better me that is surprisingly accurate
well done you know it well done I'll
take it before and after you to boycott
pretty accurate pretty goddamn already
look how happy I was look how better
days were right around the corner but
they also took one thing I didn't know
they could take my quality content
because I should not have been funny it
really shouldn't running out of video
ideas asking other people for video
ideas asking big perfect creating
another YouTube channel and pretending
that you are beginning their youtuber
begging for food by asking jacksepticeye
to temporarily hold your channel while
you go back to packing through Japan
with it I really just thought about
having Jack take over the channel for a
day [ __ ] how do they know hey it's your
super driver Here I am outside I would I
would ride with that over I would five
stars [ __ ] on that Hoover
Mitra y-you guys owe me hahaha you the
girl he tells you not to worry about I'm
done like what ten you laughs you lose
videos oh I'm sorry
back in day today it was totally fine
but here oh when people ask how many
times a day I make billions and millions
I like that because it's a subtle pretty
pie meme but also very much in your face
to get it for those newcomers I like it
appreciate it my name is Nick come to it
no I'm not from Compton
English is my city few pies are not seed
scare PewDiePie season to cancel free
pies no original ideas city fires make
billion why why did that become a meme
the [ __ ] business yeah I love all
things I don't understand you guys but
hey [ __ ] it we do look extremely cute
here I'm not going to lie me and Mark
see I are really couple going
did Brad submit this or what the hell
all right everyone we need more ideas
for original content green-screen
competition meme competition cross that
slaughter shop competition that's right
everyone we're doing a Photoshop
competition and you could win I'm going
to download the pictures that I posted
in the description and Photoshop it
whatever way you want whatever way you
please I see as people you're doing here
trying to make fun of me for not having
original content but to be honest I I
love these so much it's so fun to see
the community come together and with the
same [ __ ] weird humor as me and doing
this stupid [ __ ] so if you want to be
part of that I think it's awesome I
really appreciate it it makes me feel
like I'm not just you dare [ __ ] I
don't want to express my feelings ok
it's cool it's cool to see you guys
taken part of that if the sisters being
part of that respecting women community
we're at 55 million subscribers now this
one is beautiful it's a classic